hallo mein name ist sogar endlich
bekommen wir heute zu einem hobby heute
ein youtuber dabei nicht wenn der welt
noch einen kanal mit der gezeigt habe
ich respektiere seinen content der
hanomag
wir haben uns heute ein format überlegt
was wir euch nicht präsentieren werden
von daher würde ich sagen das ist auf
jeden fall vorbei ich habe ein paar
kleine v ausschnitte und youtube
danke
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
[Musik]
fertig sein der erste song den man immer
denkt bei youtube im ersten moment
dürfte also richtig ist letztlich ein
millionen erster punkt danke 10
[Musik]
vorbei
für rath alter sei schwierig
robert kennen in der richtigen
reihenfolge ich mein bein raummitte
deutsche fonds eigentlich nativer
youtuber gestellt einfach ein paar
fragen mehr als eine million abonnenten
erhalten
david aufgekommen
kann man das wirklich nie darauf
gekommen setzt du mit dem türkischen
aber auf jeden fall ein du ein paar
damen herren
[Applaus]
apa/red photoshop photoshop über
kabarett direkte ab 341 spielcafé ich
möchte gar nicht aber ich habe es mal
schaffen
[Musik]
bekannt vor
die mal dreirad was ich kann jetzt
wieder völlig neu gestrichen
9 millionen 9 millionen views okay ich
wusste dass es die man nur von klima
dieses dreirad lied ich kann das wieder
zueinander 800 millionen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
pablo heras scheiß auf jeden fall pause
ist auf jeden fall
es ist schön weil da wollte ich
eigentlich sagen dass das ist was er da
oben auf dem berg bekommt weil er
falsche gesagt hat und 100 kg sie gemein
[Musik]
es ist eine youtuber der er musik macht
es seinem kanal ein türkischstämmiger
motive okay wenn du meinst die vorwärts
wegen also denke ich im gegenteil in
form wirklich einem tückischen oder
einem youtuber der musik was würde ich
sagen die leute verstimmt voll dass
bushido für diese art weitere sp zu
betonen beide kämpfernaturen künstler
sagen wenn ein künstler trifft kriegt
auch er vergab drei millionen mal gehört
ja wohl nicht von ihrer linie werk
bushido und professionell
das sind
[Musik]
aber ich spüre wenn es nach bushido
klingt für euch dann schöpfen die kunst
steht nach wie vor ort ihren zu den
letzten beiden unentschieden auf
irgendwen zu geht noch eine weile chef
ein weiteres team aus beraten wir machen
sein und hat eine platte die ganze zeit
gedacht dass wir sind endlich an daten
werden dann schreib einfach lieber habe
ich das noch nicht denke ich an meine
eigenen meine eigene video idee aber
diese spricht genauso das theater kennen
bushido und ich finde ich finde bushido
ich finde die debatte war in laptop
macbook air sei mehrdeutig die gefallen
hat bin auf jeden fall bushido und wie
man ungarn auch wieder gemeinsamkeiten
wir beide meinten beide veganen weiter
mit
[Gelächter]
ja ich bin das genie hinter dem video
hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen hier heute zu einem neuen
video e3 haben uns gedacht dass wir
heute mal die ab und zu dritt machen
deswegen will ich sagen ich hoffe euch
das video gefallen wir hoffen das glaube
ich alle werden solche feier ist auf
jeden fall waren kehrten leichter die
beiden kanäle von denen bin unten in der
beschreibung verlinkt also checkt ist
auf jeden fall mal haben diese leute ich
finde ein wild witzig und wichtig auch
wenn man oder man fünf minuten versuchen